another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do with the foundation no playing hot  potato with scp-963  scp-963 is the ornate anomalous amulet  that contains dr jack bright's  consciousness any living subject that  comes into contact with this amulet  ceases brain function and their  consciousness is replaced with dr  brights if they remain in contact with  the amulet for longer than 30 days they  will retain this consciousness even  after the amulet has been removed  otherwise they will experience brain  death essentially it should be taken  incredibly seriously and handled with  great care it should not be tossed at a  random d-class research assistant or any  other foundation staff member with  shouts of catch or use to play any other  high-stakes contact-based game it is not  in fact a fun team-building exercise  that should be played on company  retreats